hey this is presh talwalkar
a version of this question was asked on
a cambridge entrance exam
of the five grids
one grid is shaded completely correctly
each of the other four grids has exactly
one shaded square wrong
which grid is correct
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
the only way to be completely sure of
the answer is to go through each
possibility
let's do that first
let's first compare grids a and c
suppose grid a was the correct
grid then grid c would have exactly one
square different from grid a
however we can see that grid c has two
squares that are different from grid a
by the reverse logic this shows that
grid c cannot be the correct grid
because if grid c was the correct grid
then grid a would have to have exactly
one square different from grid c
so we know that neither a nor c can be
the correct answer
similarly let's consider if grid b were
the answer
well in this case grids b and c differ
by two squares
so again grid b cannot be the answer
what about grid d
again grid c differs by two squares from
grid d so d cannot be the answer
this leaves e as the only possibility
in fact e is the correct answer and we
can check that all of the other four
grids differ from grid e by exactly one
square
now just for fun i want to show another
way to solve the problem
let's overlap these grids on top of each
other and let's make it so that if two
grids have squares in the same spot
we'll shade the squares darker
here's a result when all five grids are
placed on top of each other
now wherever the squares are darker will
be our guess of the correct squares
so this leads to the following guess of
what the correct grid would be
similarly where the squares are lighter
shaded would be the squares that are the
ones that are incorrect from the correct
grid
we can actually see that these incorrect
squares would correspond to the grids a
b c and d
these are exactly where
those grids differ from grid e
so once again we can actually see that
grid e is the correct grid
and thus the other four are wrong
so e is the correct answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you